[Música]
tenho que conquistar o la nación em 1981
naquela época eu escutava que o brasil é
o país do futuro
naquela época também o cantei que essa
aqui é um país que vai pra frente tem a
minha idade vai lembrar da musiquinha
também ouvia naquele momento que esse
futuro ele não vim agora essa potência
de grande nação não se tornava em ato
por culpa do governo que tinha ditadura
conseguimos a liberdade a democracia vai
nos trazer todos de volta
eu vi a redemocratização era um momento
de festa e muita alegria
finalmente o futuro chegou é agora nosso
futuro também não vinha a dizer que tem
um problema o problema econômico
problema econômico a inflação quanto
resolver a tal da inflação esquece de
tem jeito não vi tentativas sucessivas
de acabar com a inflação
algumas delas chegaram a mobilizar o
país inteiro das pessoas orgulhosas
dizendo eu defendo esse plano fiscal
lembraram né
talvez você tenha sido se arrependeu né
mas nós vimos o país construir algo que
a gente chama de responsabilidade fiscal
eu só estabilidade agora vai vai
não foi mas não era só isso agora a
inflação não tem mais uma para resolver
a desigualdade país é muito igual
nós vimos eleição atrás de eleição
girando em torno do mesmo tema reduzir
desigualdades
nós vimos isso acontecendo todas
igualdade é resolver o problema da
criminalidade em toda a desigualdade
melhorou a condição de quem está em
baixo o crime cai na academia nem se
estudava segurança pública para se ter
uma idéia precisa da questão econômica
veio o crescimento econômico veio e
edson do contato social
mas o futuro esse aí não vêem o que veio
ela lava jato
o que veio é talvez a maior desilusão
desse período histórico que eu narrei
aqui a gente se acostuma olhar para o
futuro e enxergar alguma coisa hoje a
gente olha para o futuro e não enxerga
nada é um vazio é um vazio
a gente olha diz ferrou para não usar
uma expressão que talvez nunca é bem um
vídeo não é talvez a filosofia possa nos
ajudar neste momento
nesse momento de aflição neste momento
de vazio neste momento de desesperança
profunda nesse momento em que nós
começamos a desconfiar de nós mesmos
como nação se olhar no espelho e
perguntar onde é que a gente pra
cachorro
vou usar aqui um conceito emprestado
emprestado de algo que domina o nosso
dia-a-dia da computação adr software
está tão imerso nesse mundo da
tecnologia a dor software
tudo aquilo que eu descrevi agora há
pouco como sendo aquelas condições para
se atingir o futuro a gente pode chamar
de água da política
o sistema político sistema eleitoral de
preferir a democracia não é eleição
indireta não é mesmo
mesmo na economia que plano que projeto
árdua
mas é um software
nós temos uma crise no nosso hardware
que não é de hoje mas a novidade é que
nós temos uma crise no software da
política
o software é a idéia que nos une
o software é aquele futuro que nós
enxergávamos lá longe
vou dar um exemplo puxando mais pra
filosofia porque pra falar de filosofia
tem que falar de filósofo e filósofo tem
que ser grego antigo morto há muito
tempo se não desconfiam palestra de
filosofias em grego negócio assim que
está faltando alguma coisa né
platão tratamos a uma primeira ideia
sobre política o primeiro software uma
idéia comungada de política que nos
permite julgar da vida que nós vivemos
se é bom ou se é ruim do nosso projecto
de vida compartilhada que a política se
é bom ou se é ruim
estamos no caminho certo no caminho
errado ele dizia que para além desse
mundo que nós vivemos o mundo das coisas
mundo da natureza a outro mundo um mundo
das idéias ideia não sinônimo coisa que
eu pensei idéia no sentido de ideal
aqui tem um mundo do jeito que ele é
com alegrias e tristezas sucessos e
fracassos
essa vida que a gente bem conhece
a montanha russa nos avassala de vez em
inglês
mas para além disso além dessa oscilação
além da desigualdade a um ideal que um
só imutável permanente está lá
nesse outro mundo não aqui com esse
outro mundo nós temos uma ligação que é
espiritual espiritual leia-se mental
espiritual de latinha palavra fica
melhor
anima alma animal aquilo que me move
aquilo que nos movimenta aquilo que nos
faz pensar aquilo que nos torna não
coisa inerte do mundo mas coisa ativa no
mundo a mente você preferir a nossa
mente consegue button acredita
lembrar-se psd ao lembrar-se porque você
espírito já teve lá saiu de lá e vim pra
cá né
aí com esse corpo mortal de prendendo e
adoecendo de entristecendo dando alegria
quando se encontra um pudim pela frente
ou coisa parecida mas aí sua mortalidade
está nesse corpo não está no espírito
pois bem o seu espírito imortal na
imortal só para o futuro é passado
também que no passado viu o ideal é se
esse corpo que seguia cheio de desejo
se ele não perturbar demais o seu
espírito
só a sua razão prevalecerá em
prevalecendo a razão o que vai criar sua
ação a sua conduta o que vai demover em
pensamento e movimento mesmo no mundo
vai ser esse ideal
nossa tão fácil todo mundo pode mais ou
menos é porque tem gente que não tem
jeito de plantão ele era um padre
petista tem gente que tá tão dominada
pelo corpo e pelo desejo que esse ideal
ele não prevalece então como nós devemos
fazer tesch aqueles para quem o ideal é
claro governar os outros
os filósofos olha que beleza
esse é um discurso que nos dão a
narrativa de como a vida é
ao descrever o mundo ideal uma narrativa
de como o mundo deve ser ainda nos dá
uma fórmula para identificar a quem
seguir a quem seguir aquilo que nós
podemos dizer um discurso de
legitimidade
o software da política como nós
imaginamos como devemos ser onde vamos
chegar
como escolher a quem nós vamos nos
submeter um software dado esse idealismo
ele muda de conteúdo ao longo do tempo
nem todo mundo repete literalmente as
mesmas idéias de plantão
nem todo mundo fala do ideal do mesmo
jeito que platão dizia mas todos
apresentam ideais variados
a maior parte da nossa história política
marcada por isso uma sucessão de ideais
esse é um software da política
uma sucessão de ideais que ora é quando
o proletariado todos se unir
aí sim nós vamos ter aquele país aquela
nação aquela sociedade que nós tanto
queremos e desejamos sem desigualdade
todo mundo limpo se beijando e abraçando
se a mão de festa velho o diesel não vai
ser assim é deixando o homem seu que é
nas suas relações livres sem nenhuma má
a gente se ajeitar em mão invisível do
mercado vai resolver um discurso tão
idealista quanto o outro
socialistas e liberais irmanados no
software diferentes no conteúdo mas sem
a mesma marca de software todos
conseguem apresentar um futuro todos
conseguem mostrar o futuro se hoje nós
não vemos hoje nós descrevemos de quem
fala isso é porque esse software parou
de rodar e software foi arrasado pelas
nossas práticas cotidianas arrasado
pelas mudanças que a sociedade sofreu
hoje o secretário de estado do espírito
santo
veja a política de perto é legal
escreveu um livro sobre maquiavel que
foi também alguém que teve a carreira de
estado é a partir daí produzir uma baita
obra filosófica
eu fiz o caminho um pouco inverso eu
comecei a escrever depois fui para os
bastidores de como acontecia eu digo
nossa ver como a queda tinha razão
eu vejo de perto o software funcionar
com lente de aumento
algumas questões que havia proposto o
software
ele disse que o ideal não funciona
esquece idealismo esquece pega o
príncipe não é o maior livro dele não
mais completo mas é o que todo mundo lê
pelo menor sucesso editorial é
inversamente proporcional ao número de
páginas para você que está batalhando no
mercado literário tem uma lição
ele começa o príncipe dizendo como
conquistar e manter o poder
o discurso realista posto o tempo de
maquiavel dizia
sabe nos fazia crer que essa pergunta é
descabida
como assim o discurso posto o ideal de
então para maquiavel é a idéia de que
deus criou o mundo e deus organismo
mundo e na organização do mundo deus
escolheu alguns pra nascer em nobres e
outros para serem pobres portanto se
reúnam surreal que sorte sorte e mais
nada a gente aprende história que seu
direito divino dos reis é porque você é
rei e deus quiser vai nem queria tava de
deus botou aqui fazer o quê
agora tenho que carregar este fardo é
barato quem está ali fala que é fácil né
pergunta quem está do lado de fora
maquiavel disso tudo bem
tem gente que chega ao poder pela sorte
mas na única forma não tem outras pela
conquista pega o exército vai lá e toma
o inimigo vai pelo crime
o seu 17º na linha de sucessão matos 16
que vem antes chegou a sua vez
há tantas formas a tantas formas mas o
mais fundamental depende da gente
depende práticas mas o software ainda
está incompleto porque ele está apenas
fazendo discurso anti idealismo contra o
idealismo da época ela substituísse
idealismo por outro é preciso substituir
esse software por outro o software que
ele usa a ideia de natureza humana
a política é o que é porque nós somos o
que somos a política nada mais é do que
a consequência dos nossos encontros do
mundo e quem somos nós para maquiavel
seres desejantes somos guiados pelo
desejo e desejo para maquiavel é o mesmo
que desejo para platão atração por
aquilo que não se tem uma força que
seguia baseada na falta a gente só
deseja o que não tem aquilo que tem você
não deseja mais você despreza carro bom
é o carro que você não tem publicitário
sabe muito bem disso que relançou as
mesmas coisas mas tem que dizer que no
elenco uma vez eu fui comprar vídeo
cassete na época em que alguém da
comprava vídeo cassete
z tem tempo esse negócio eu chego lá pro
vendedor tem dois iguaizinhos embaixo a
caixa e qual o preço é diferente não
custava 30 contra mais um pergunta qual
a diferença meu amigo eu sou xx com a
gxs de 43
esse é o gx kz 27 jan tá com a diferença
e se tenha exclusiva função digital
cristal vídeo falando inglês parece
muito mais sair o negócio
nossa o que ele faz
átomos de carbono nizam na ea radiação
melhor a imagem
falei tá paguei os 30 contra levei para
casa ficava olhando a tv ligava o
controle tecla digital cristal vídeo
acende uma luz azul no painel do vídeo
cassete e mais nada
eu olhava imagem de perto com olavo
nariz da tv para seu seio não é ligava e
desligava ligava e desligava a imagem
era a mesma a mesma eu paguei 30 conta
um led já atacaram hoje por esse preço
não foi bem leve e você sabe
a idéia do novo porque o novo vende o
novo é legal não é esse
não é isso somos assim desejamos o que
não temos e por isso pra pensar as
nossas interações para pensar as
relações de poder
é preciso pensar o desejo maquiavel
descreve a política em partidos não do
jeito que a gente conhece no espectro
horizontal divididos entre a direita ea
esquerda mas um critério vertical é quem
está por cima e quem está por baixo
velho
quantas vezes você não viu quem estava
por baixo fazer um discurso e no dia em
que está lá em cima faz outro igual do
cara que tava lá em cima antes para quem
está em baixo tudo é fácil tudo é
possível só não faz porque não tem
vontade política
aí quando tá lá em cima às vezes a
vontade política não é assim tem esse
problema tem orçamento tem limite tem a
lei tem né
tem o povo às vezes o que se pede são
coisas que esqueceu de perguntar pra
todo mundo pensa política como jogo de
força e virar maquiavel tirar maquiavel
mas em maquiavel podia pensar o mundo de
hoje um mundo em que a tecnologia
revolucionou as relações humanas mundo
como diz um amigo meu
na política já teve mandato ele dizia
isso aqui ó
esse aparelhinho e lehmann se pouco o
eleitor dizer com espanto e tristeza
emancipou para entender essa emancipação
fui líder estudantil na época do
impeachment do collor
nós vimos no rio de janeiro para reunião
da une na rua do catete o que se
discutir na reunião da onu três coisas
quando nós vamos pra rua e lugar quando
de hora e lugar e que faixas nós vamos
levar as duas discussões são muito úteis
na segunda parte engraçada discutir por
exemplo se a gente apoiar os cultos do
cazaquistão em pleno impeachment do
collor e 19 os curdos estão só esperando
o apoio da gente para resolver toda a
questão pode botar a faixa de encontrar
agora veja
temos que nos entender que nós saímos
dali
iremos para o diretório central chamada
presidente grêmio e dizia tal dia toda
hora presidente grêmio o grêmio chamava
líder de turma e dizia tal dia a hora de
ir e de tuma chegava na sala de aula e
dizia ao dia e da hora ea galera ia tudo
bem tinha tv ajudando mas quem ia
sincronizar era um sincronizador de
ações coletivas mas com a tecnologia de
hoje
dispensável pra que você nem sair de
casa possa lá evento galera vai e começa
a bombar e começa a compartilhar e
acontece sem ninguém ter visto antes
isso te tono o software da política aqui
de intermediário que agregava
isso dificulta vender software idealista
das pessoas e talvez seja o caso
ao apelar para a filosofia para entender
o mundo que nós vivemos tentar entender
não mais o conteúdo mas a engenharia de
software que a política se boa parte dos
discursos o poder são discursos de
legitimação legitimação de um projeto ou
legitimação de alguém que representa o
projeto
então meu amigo talvez seja o caso de
nós pensarmos como as legislações são
construídas e não qual o conteúdo do
legítimo a outro autor
michel ficou contemporâneo tá morto
também que filósofo já sabe que vai ser
consagrada está morto mas contemporâneo
porque mundo que ele descreve
estranhamente nos é muito família muito
família
ele vai dizer o seguinte como
consequência de nós pensarmos política
como ideal
nós pensávamos política como o legítimo
nós acabamos fazendo crer e falando de
política como se fosse uma coisa que se
tem do poder como uma coisa que se tem
eu tenho o poder e que se traduz o ter
poder e alguns símbolos símbolos de
status
lembro que uma vez encontrei uma pessoa
famosa muito rica preso hoje envolvido
no escândalo zin
mas acho que continua rica mas ele chega
eu eu associei a cara né a pessoa estava
na cara que era rico um risco evidente
assim como eu identifiquei era pela
roupa pela cara pelo sujeito que tinha
também cada evidente de segurança
esse é o software tem mensagens que nós
passamos que diz quem é rico e quem é
pobre
eu vou dar um exemplo para você entender
minha esposa esposa trabalhava numa
empresa que importava e distribui vinhos
veja quando fazia evento a degustação de
vinho promover um produto
eu não gosto de mim eu tomo mas estou
longe de ser aquela firula dos enólogos
quando eu chego na prova sabe todo
misancene as pessoas dizem professor
favors o primeiro eu pego vou tomar diz
não não que tá errada à cerrada em casa
a gente deve copo de requeijão passa
errada
qual é a certa é essa nossa tem regra
tem regra boto vim eu vou beber não tem
que provar o que o que é um seria o
cheiro não é porque ele chorava e dizia
atacou carvalho sente carvalho falei
'não sinto vinho vai vendo lavaram sua
taça
eu sou bom pode seguir vinho branco do
tinto pela cor passou daí você entendeu
exemplo feito todo misancene você que
não é do mundo do vinho que não comunga
o jargão do vinho que não leu aí nos
perfeita
vocês têm extrema e você se sente
extremamente desconfortável quando se
senta no restaurante é alguém diz vamos
escolher um vinho e ela escolhe você não
eu não entendo disso você diz autorizado
a falar de vinho isso que a gente usa no
mundo do vinho é uma lógica que se usa
em todas as relações sociais
focou chamava de saber é um saber que
nos faz crer que nos faz julgar o que é
um bom projeto e o que não é o nosso
momento a nossa encruzilhada essa
precisamos de lideranças para
reconstruir software para reconstruir os
saberes que nos unem e não mais aquela
liderança que é o cara que vem aqui
resolvi tudo
o governo estadual com o projeto os
jovens foi apresentar resultados no
bairro onde o projeto acontece um dos
mais violentos do estado
disseram legal quando você fala o vejo
olho brilhando
eu acredito em você eu falei que não tem
que acreditar em mim você tem que
acreditar em você porque aquela política
feita só por um aquela idéia de que o
estado dá conta de tudo isso não cabe
mais um software o estado é parte da
sociedade
a gente tem que resolver um problema da
sociedade inteira tem que reinventar
modos de convivência
nessa era de novas tecnologias nós todos
juntos têm que confiar em você em você e
no que você pode fazer pra nos
organizarmos como um todo como sociedade
o caminho juntos ou então nosso futuro
vai continuar sendo
só a imagem futura só musiquinha legal
só discurso só desejo nunca realidade
obrigado
[Aplausos]